you
well there was a study done probably
about eight years ago that looked at the
success of startups and the what the
rate at which they had exits and and
then another researcher Scott Shane
looked at those numbers and realized
that my god University startups are over
a hundred times more likely to go public
than a typical startup which is
staggering and the so you might ask why
why is that the case and I really
believe that it's because so when you
when you're trying to create a
high-growth company and what in a good
rubric for that would be to think about
you so what would what would a venture
capitalist be willing to invest in
because they see a big exit at a later
date pretty hot you know in the short
term then is something that has a real
sustainable competitive advantage and
that usually means some sort of
intellectual property and some sort of a
technology that enables something to
scale quickly so that describes a lot of
the research that's happening in
university research labs so I think that
that's one of the reasons why university
startups and them really the ones that
come out are the ones that that are
based on some really groundbreaking
pioneering research and have some sort
of intellectual property that enables
the company to to scale some idea
quickly I would go back to even just
really basic concepts like the internet
and biotechnology and those created
whole new industries so then no those
came from universities the internet was
first the first email exchanges between
UCLA and stanford and then several other
universities have have were working on
it together and then it grew and if it
weren't for the university is having to
communicate with each other then the
internet would have never happened
probably and biotechnology was a
was a whole industry that was based on
the comb Boyer patent that was licensed
by Stanford not exclusively too many new
biotech companies so in another example
is this is a little more obscure a lot
of people haven't heard of this but
there's something called the moses
platform for creating semiconductor
chips and it's run out of the University
of Southern California information
Sciences Institute and any student that
has a chip design they want to test out
what are they going to do are they going
to build a three billion dollar fab in
Asia of course they can't do that but
they can send it by email to or through
the internet to Moses and it will create
a wafer for them and test out their
design and so I think they've done
50,000 designs for students and
researchers around the world and so that
those are the kind of things that enable
a whole industry and enable new
innovations to crop up